thank you for having me my name is nikki
freed i am a researcher at the
university of auckland in new zealand
i also run the university of auckland's
core genome sequencing facility called
auckland genomics however today i will
be talking about work that i did while i
was a senior lecturer at massey
university last year and this is work
in which we developed a method which we
call the midnight panel or midnight
method
for rapid and inexpensive whole genome
sequencing of stars code ii the virus
that causes code 19.
so before i really launch into the
details of how we do the genome
sequencing i just wanted to briefly
touch on what genome sequencing is why
it's important i think most people
understand this at this point in the
pandemic however i just want to make
sure we're all on the same page
so this is a diagram from the new york
times and the outer circle here
represents
the
genome of the virus so stars cov2 has a
it's a single stranded rna
genome it's about 30 000 nucleotides
long
and this inner circle here represents
just the virus itself
so when i talk about sequencing the
genome i'm talking about trying to
sequence that entire 30 000 nucleotides
and the reason why we do this
is that as most people know the virus
changes and mutates over time
certain mutations fix
this is again an image from new york
times of the alpha
variant of concern or b117
so you can see here there are lines sort
of coming out from the center circle and
those indicate non-synonymous mutations
so changes to the nucleotide
sequence that have changed the amino
acid sequence which may be functionally
important
so these lines indicate mutations that
have happened that have fixed in this
alpha variant of concern
sorry and there are also
some deletions shown here as well so you
can see that
changes
um occur throughout the genome
also not shown here are uh there are a
large number of synonymous mutations as
well so changes to the nucleotide
sequence
so it is important to sequence the
entire 30 000 nucleotides to really
capture
all of the changes that have happened to
the virus over time
so when we talk about sequencing that's
what we're doing we're sequencing the
whole 30 000 nucleotides
so why do we do this why do we sequence
the genome why is that important well
it's important to as i mentioned track
the emergence and the frequencies of
these variants of concern i think know
most people right now delta has spread
throughout the world so we'll talk a
little bit about that
sequencing the virus also allows us to
understand how it evolves so what
mechanisms of mutations are occurring
things like that
it also allows us especially in a new
zealand context so i'm located in new
zealand we use real time genomic
sequencing to help us track local
outbreaks and understand frozen
transmission events
so this is a slide from covariance.org
this is a website run by emma hodcroft
in switzerland
and basically what this site does is it
takes and it accesses g said which is a
global data repository which um
currently has about four million
covid or sarskov ii genomes
which has been running since the
beginning of the pandemic
so what this website does is it allows
you to look at for different countries
around the world the frequencies of
these variants of concern
and as you can see here this is just
one of the one of the plots that i've
pulled from covariance from for the u.s
and you can see that delta has rapidly
fixated and become dominant in the u.s
and is now actually dominant globally
so
by sequencing the genome we can track
the frequencies of these variants of
concern and understand what's happening
in that space
oops sorry
so
as i mentioned in new zealand and we use
real-time genomic sequencing to help us
track outbreaks
you may recognize this is our prime
minister jacinda ardern speaking with
joke delict from esr
he's one of the scientists involved in
collating all of the data from new
zealand and he's explaining to her and
they're discussing the phylogeny of
the sars cov2 sequences that were
present in new zealand at the beginning
of the pandemic
so i'll talk a little bit more about how
we use that sequencing and why that's
important
so we've also written a paper on this
this is um
if you're interested to to understand
more about how you can use genomics to
track
disease outbreaks we've written a paper
on that in emerging infectious diseases
so that's available
if you're interested in that
my role was primarily in developing the
method for
rapid real-time genomic sequencing so
that's what i'll be talking about today
and before i begin that i just want to
give a little bit of background so our
method that we developed is really built
on
what's called the arctic method
so i'm going to give a little bit of a
timeline describe a little bit about the
arctic method and then talk about how
our method
is
has modified and made two big
modifications to the
this method
so in january early january of 2020 the
first full genome of stars cov2 was
released this was
achieved by doing meta-genomic
sequencing which is
um
not the most efficient way to sequence
the genome for routine sequencing
so
january 23rd so 11 days later josh quick
and the arctic network released a method
for which was called the arctic method
for amplifying the virus and then
sequencing it using nanopore sequencing
so this is incredibly fast and they have
a long background in
the arctic network is heavily involved
in tracking disease outbreaks such as
ebola zika virus et cetera so they were
very
poised to do this work and they did an
excellent job and i would say
the majority of sequences around the
world are probably produced using this
method
so the way in which the arctic method
works
i'll give a little bit of background
here so they
here
at the top of the screen you can see
another
graphical representation of the genome
so again it's a 30 000 nucleotide
rna genome so the first stage if you
want to sequence the whole genome
is
to do a reverse transcription so it's a
little bit easier to sequence dna than
rna so first step is changing the rna
genome into cdna
oops sorry about that
the next step is to do a multiplex pcr
so
in two different pools um you can use a
tiled amplicon approach so
that there are no overlapping amplicons
so in pool a and every other
basically
the arctic method uses this tiled
amplicon approach so that they're
amplify the genome in 400 base pair
segments that are um
not overlapping essentially
so this takes it uses 196 primers and
creates about 98 amplicons to amplify
the entire genome
so at this stage you have two pools
and you can combine those pools and then
sequence them either using illumina
chemistry or oxford nanopore chemistry
so today i'm going to focus more on the
oxford nanopore sequencing
because that's the method that we use in
the midnight method to sequence um to
sequence stars cove2
so right now i'm going to give a little
bit of background if you're not familiar
with nanopore sequencing just to
describe what nanopore sequencing is
i always leave the slide in for my my
kids love the slide
um
so nanopress sequencing has been around
we've been using it for microbial genome
sequencing since about 2017.
it's a portable real-time sequencer
you can see it fits in your hand it's a
min ion not a minion
basically in a nutshell
so well now it comes in a range of
different devices so you can see the
original mid ion is here and there's now
a grid ion and promethian and
different sort of range of devices that
will deliver
different amounts of data
and i always like to remind myself to
say you know i'm not affiliated or paid
by nanopore sequencing or by oxford
nanopore at all um i've just been using
the technology for a long time and i'm a
big fan
so some of the key attributes of
nanopore sequencing are that it's a long
read sequencer so
you basically the length of dna that you
put into the sequencer is the length
that you will sequence so you people
have you know gotten single reads over a
million or even actually now four
million base pairs long in a single read
typically we
achieve about five to fifty thousand
base pair median read lengths
so at its heart it's a long read long
read sequencing device
it directly sequence native it directly
sequences native dna and rna
and by directly sequencing the native
dna rna you can detect base pair
modifications so if you're interested in
epigenetics
methylation um it detects
5-methylcytomine 5-methylamine and other
other modifications
so these things i've just described um
are not so critical for sarsko v2
sequencing however the next two the ones
with the little star so the fact that
this is a portable sequencer like i said
the minion plugs into um your laptop or
even a small like ipad device
there are no overhead costs
so
as opposed to illumina sequencing you
don't have to purchase a large sequencer
that can cost you know 100 000 or more
you basically just pay for consumables
only also what's really nice about
nanopore sequencing is it doesn't
require a lot of expertise to use um you
need some background in molecular
biology but it's
it's fairly
robust it also what's important for our
method for sequencing stars co2 is it
sequences in real time so we were really
focused on
making sure that the method that we used
was really rapid
and so that's one of the key attributes
of why we're
why we use nanopore sequencing
okay so
for many people who aren't that familiar
with nanopore sequencing the first thing
that they ask is ah i don't know i've
heard it's not very accurate
so what about
the accuracy so
it is imp nanopore sequencing has
improved accuracy significantly
um
over time
i think they are achieving single read
accuracy at around 98.3
so if you're familiar with quality
scores from illumina that's around the
quality score of 18.
however consensus rate accuracy is
really very accurate so over 99.999
which is over a quality score of 40. so
this is very comparable with illumina
and sequencing so if you so what i mean
by consensus read accuracy as well is if
you sequence the same molecule say 30
times or 50 times then you can have a
very high level of accuracy
and also there are papers so james
ferguson has done
just a little tweet from him in december
of 2020 um there are people who have
benchmarked nanopore
sequencing against illumina sequencing
for sars cove 2 and have shown that you
they're comparable and that you can
clearly call snips with nano for
sequencing so this is um
a good way to sequence stars code too
okay so coming back
to the
arctic method where you have your
stars cov2 genome amplified in these 400
base pair fragments you've in this case
we're gonna choose to use nanopore
sequencing
what the arctic method does is they use
a ligation kit from oxford nanopore
details here aren't too important and
what i've circled here is the time it
takes so this process of ligating
the barcodes on and the sequencing
adapters so that you can put your that
amplified dna onto the min ion sequencer
or or
nanopore flow cell
it takes around 135 minutes and it
requires
some pretty expensive third-party
reagents
um
so this is fine if you're an experienced
user and have
time but it is a little bit um
difficult for people who aren't very
experienced
however it does work fine so that's
great
i just want to highlight that because
that is a change that we've made
to our method
okay what is also great is the arctic
network has um developed software for
real-time sequencing analysis so this is
called rampart but this is a software
tool so as i said when you're sequencing
with nanopore sequencing you add your
dna to the flow cell and data starts
being written almost immediately
so what this software does is in real
time as you start sequencing it will
create a coverage plot for you so this
is hard to see but these little peaks on
the left in blue
illus
coverage plots of the genome so you can
see in real time
how much data you've collected and if
your entire genome has been sequenced to
say 30x coverage or 50x coverage
it also does real-time phylogenetic
analysis so it will tell you
which variant of concern you have for
which sample so this is a really um
great tool to use because it allows you
just to collect the amount of data that
you need
and at that stage once you've achieved
the amount of data that you want say
100x coverage of all of your you know 12
or 25 24 genomes then you can actually
turn the flow cell off wash it and use
it for something else so in that way it
helps save money as well
and time so you can finish sequencing um
just you can finish sequencing once
you've
collected the amount of data that you
need
so some of the initial results so when
we started um as i mentioned i started
looking into developing a method for uh
cyrus co2 genome sequencing in about
march or april of 2020
and so at this time the arctic method
had has already gone through a couple
iterations of their primer scheme
so as i said in january josh quick 11
days after
the first genome was um released josh
built this version one of the primer
sequences so this is an example of
coverage plots i should say so on the x
axis we have the stars co2 genomic
location and on the y axis is the
coverage
and you can see in these pink bars at
the bottom here you can see that there
are dips in coverage so some amplicons
just failed to amplify
however
for a completely you know untested and
so they released this without actually
testing it on real samples at this stage
they didn't have a real sample so just
for an insilico
method of testing this worked really
well to be honest the first time
i think josh describes this as a bit of
primer whack-a-mole i've heard him say
so
because version one there were a few
primers that didn't work they developed
a version two primer and
while some
primers um were
you know
they could fix some of the primers at
the same time then other primers dropped
out
so they then developed a third version
of the primers and this is um one that's
been in use for a long time they've just
recently released a version four
um however at the time that we started
doing this we
had access to version three
in march of 2020
and at that stage you could already see
that there were some
um significant
there are significant variance in the
amount of coverage that can be produced
with the version three of the primers
you'll see on the left or sorry on the
right here this is a log scale so there
is a good amount of variance in the
coverage so
when we are looking at how we could
possibly improve this or use it locally
here in new zealand we looked at um
redesigning the primers
so that's something that i'll talk about
so oops
sorry
doing the wrong thing
so what i'll be talking about today is
the midnight method which is the method
we
that we use so it's a built off the
arctic method and it really just makes
two modifications to the arctic method
and that's had a
significant impact on the ability for us
to get better coverage and
produce sequence data faster
so the two sort of modifications that we
made were to change the amplicon length
so we made longer amplicons and that
enables us to get
more even coverage of the genome
this also by making the
amplicons longer that means that we use
fewer primers
and the idea here was to produce less
cross reactivity so there's less
chance for those primers to cross react
and potentially that means that there'll
be fewer dropouts
also having fewer primers as the virus
changes over time
there's less of a chance that the primer
will mismatch with the genome so you'll
have less dropouts
potentially fewer dropouts
however
one drawback there is that if you do
have a dropout with longer amplicons you
will lose more sequencing data so
there's a bit of a trade-off by choosing
to use longer amplicons
however these primers have held up
fairly well
against most variants of concerns that
we see now
another modification that we made was to
use
oxford nanopore's rapid library prep kit
so this is a much faster
cheaper and easier to use kit
at the time that when we were developing
this there were only 12 barcodes
available they have since released 96 so
that allows us to do many samples at
once
so those i'm going to talk about those
two modifications a bit more in detail
so we initially tested three different
primer sets um we tested a 1200 base
pair primer set a 1 500 base pair primer
set and a 2 000 base pair
um
primer set which creates longer
amplicons
so at the time when we did this we
didn't know if any of these would work
um
so we gave a shot and tried three
different ones
and we used a multiplex pcr a very
similar method to
the arctic networks
the way in which they do their multiplex
pcr so again it's a tiled amplicon
approach where you have non-overlapping
segments of the genome amplified in two
different pools
the next modification that we made was
to use the lap the library prep from
oxford nanopore as i said which is
called the rapid kit this is the
rbk101110 or the rbk-004 kit from oxford
nanopore
again um don't want to get into the
details too much but basically this is a
transposon based method it's a much
faster kit to use so approximately 10
minutes
of
prepping that dna to put on the flow
cell as opposed to 135 minutes
it also requires far fewer third-party
reagents so it just requires ampere
beads
and so that makes it less expensive as
well
and given the fact that there are fewer
pipetting steps it is less prone to
you have fewer chances of making a
mistake or contaminating
your samples
okay so these are our results
so you can see here we've tried
the top red bars these are coverage
plots of using these different primer
sets so we started we compared to the
400 base pair version 3 arctic primers
using that rapid transposon based kit
and then as i said we tested a 1200 base
pair primer set 1500 and 2 000 base pair
set
you can actually see that they all work
okay so for each um
for each primer we initially tested two
different
and patient samples sars codes
covered positive patient samples at
different ct values that it's a little
bit hard to see but the top one is
a ct of 20 and the bottom one is a ct of
31
and you can see that generally speaking
the primers all work pretty well we
chose to go with that 1200 base pair
primer set this is where we get the name
midnight actually is um
1200 we thought it's sort of a little
bit like midnight or noon so we use that
name
so that 1200 baseball primer set
actually gave the best coverage it was
the most even coverage and it sort of is
that sweet spot of not being too long so
that if the rna was degraded in any way
and we
felt that
if the sequence was too long then maybe
that degradation might not work very
well so we stuck with the 1200 base pair
however the primers are also available
as a backup for anyone who wants for
1500 or 1200 base pair sorry 1500 or
2000 base pair
sequences
okay so some more of our results um
again this was published in the paper
that we
produced in may 2020 so we've just
tested very simply five different
patient samples at
high to low copy numbers
so the ct if you're if you're not
familiar with ct values that's um cycle
threshold numbers so it just gives an
indication of how much viral copy there
is
so ct20 is fairly high viral copy number
and as you move down to the blue
coverage plots you can see this is at a
ct 31.2 which has relatively low copy
number and you still get complete
coverage of the genome
um
so this primer set worked pretty well at
a range of different viral
concentrations
um actually oxford nanopore has released
other data so i've adapted this figure
from them
they have tested
sort of the limit of detection of
getting a full genome from using twist
rna control so this is a synthetic
synthetic version of the sars cove ii
virus
and they took
basically diluted it down and you can
see that around a thousand copies to
um
well around at around a thousand copies
most of your genomes have full coverage
of high quality
coverage
and usually
it's fairly easy to get
a good quality genome when you have a ct
value under 30.
if you go above 30 it can be difficult
above 35 is very very difficult to get a
full quality genome in our experience
and so usually that correlates to around
a thousand viral copies so it has
to get a full genome there's less
sensitivity than your standard
qpcr which only needs a very very small
piece of
rna to get it to work so the limit of
detection for genome sequencing is
it's a little bit higher than uh for
just standard qpcr
and this is actually true i would say
going back this is actually true for
most methods used for sequencing the
whole genome most methods have a very
similar sort of limit of detection and
that's around a thousand viral copies or
ct values um
under 30 i would say
so again what this is another figure
i've adopted from oxford nanopore this
just shows
how much time it takes to sequence 96
genomes at 200x depth so that's a
very that would produce a very high
quality genome and you can see right
around seven hours
is enough time to get
almost 100 of your genome fully
sequenced um
so usually we say actually
you know you can prepare the dna
sequence if you have under 12 samples
you can just run the sequencing for an
hour and get very high quality genomes
for those 12 samples
so this i just want to highlight this
because this is much faster than
you can get illumina data so for
illumina you have to wait until the
entire sequencing run is finished before
you can look at the data
and that can take at least 24 hours
so nanopore sequencing actually enables
you to sequence for a much shorter
amount of time yet still get high
quality genomes so that
in a new zealand context we have used
that um to our advantage and that's a
really important part of our covid
response is getting sequences in
almost in relatively real time
okay
so just to summarize um midnight method
for sarcoscope 2 genome sequencing so by
changing the primer sets we've gotten
better coverage more even coverage
that means we can collect less data
and it also means that you can get full
the full stars co2 genome faster
so this enables you to save time and
save money
and
it works pretty well changing the
library prep method results in
significantly cutting on the hands the
hands on time so from two hours over two
hours down to about 15 minutes of
hands-on time just to
and do that library prep
there are fewer pipetting steps so
that's this can reduce errors you can
use robotics to totally automate the
library prep
it's less expensive because there are no
third party enzymes that are needed and
currently nanopore sells this as a
complete kit so you just purchase the
kit and you can get all the reagents
that you need in one
this enables us to do sample today to
upload in a single working day so we can
get the
rna into the lab and in less than seven
hours you can produce full genome
sequence
uploaded like a complete assemble genome
uploaded
and actually the longest part of that is
just the pcr step which takes three and
a half hours
this is a field deployable
kit it really doesn't take a lot of
expertise
it's quite flexible in the amount of
input dna that you put in so it doesn't
need you don't need to be very precise
when you use it
so this has worked out pretty well
if you want more information
we published a paper that details
a little bit more information about this
method
in
biology methods and protocols
the method is also available
and also this biology methods and
protocols this is the open access paper
also open access we publish the
method
on protocolsio so if you want a detailed
method of exactly how to do it it's here
this has over 20 000 accessions already
so a lot of people have been looking at
this and using it
so in terms of new zealand the midnight
method has had a pretty big impact on
how we
how we use our coveted response
so for all emergency coveted sequencing
the midnight method is used
in new zealand we've been very lucky
we've had very limited community spread
of coven 19. so whenever a case appears
in the community
there is a
desire to get the sequence
see
the genome sequenced immediately so we
can better understand how the person got
infected and where that um where that
infection might have happened
so for a while we were working for the
government this has now been transferred
to a um to esr which is a central um
agency that does this but when we were
contacted by the government to do the
sequencing we were under contract to
produce the
genome sequences in less than 24 hours
and we typically could do this in under
10 hours and that also includes the time
to do the rna isolation
and you can see there are some images
here on the on the right from headlines
our media as well as the government has
been really
they've really embraced the science and
they've really
used the rapid genome sequencing to
help in our testing and our tracking of
outbreaks so this has
been really neat to see
this embraced in new zealand and used in
a
everyday context to make
to make policy
so globally the midnight method
has also had a significant impact
idt sells the midnight primers
as a pre-mixed pool so you can purchase
it so you don't need to mix all the
primers yourself and they're also
working on optimizing the primers to
balance them a little bit more even so
you get more even coverage
um
idt has sold this
these pools to over 180 organizations in
35 countries
and you can sort of see from their
website um they have a little button you
can learn a little bit more about that
and as i alluded to oxford nanopore
oxford nanopore
has released the midnight method as an
official recommended protocol so you can
see on their website um they have
you know how what approach should i use
to sequence the genome they have both
the midnight method and the arctic
method
and you can see they've sort of outlined
that you need little experience compared
um to the arctic method so midnight
method requires little experience
uses very little third-party reagents
it is a rapid prep method and it has a
quick turnaround and a low cost per
sample as compared to the arctic method
actually an oxford nanopore last about
two weeks ago have released
a high throughput kit using the midnight
method
for starsco v2 sequencing
so they've really taken the method and
scaled it and packaged it and so it
makes it much easier for
researchers to just buy one kit get all
the reagents they need and they can do
the sequencing themselves and we've
actually seen that this is being used i
have a lot of people who've contacted me
from developing countries with not a lot
of infrastructure and they're using
nanopore sequencing with our kit to
sequence a lot of genomes so this is
really good in terms of
helping the global community
understand variants of concern in
across the world so globally so i'm
really a big fan of nanopore because
it really enables the democratization of
sequencing you
places that weren't able to um sort of
have access to a lot of funding can
still do this method
so this is again from the oxford
nanopore website
and
it takes about seven and a half seven
hours 15 minutes to
produce a genome from rna
you can do thousands of samples
approximately if you
multiplex and you do a lot of samples on
one flow cell you can get the cost down
to around nine dollars and 55 cents per
genome which is a very good price us
dollars
um so this is really exciting for us to
see
the midnight method being used globally
and oxford nanopore has really
facilitated that
um you can also use the midnight method
so once you amplify the genome using the
midnight primers or the arctic
primers and you can use it as i said for
aluminum sequencing
pac-bio is another sequencing chemistry
another long read sequencing chemistry
so pac-bio also uses the midnight
primers for thyroid cov2 sequencing it's
the only
um
method that they have up on their
website
so that's been
some impact there
sorry let me i'm having a problem with
the slides there we go okay
um if you would like to use
the midnight primers with illumina
sequencing several places have also
developed um
basically transposon based methods for
um taking the midnight from
amplified zarzakovi to
genomes with the midnight method you can
then use um
transposon-based methods to shear it
down to a size that's more amenable to
alumina sequencing
so sql is one of the places that has
done that so you can go to their website
and use their method for um
preparing
this dna for illumina sequencing
idt also has a kit they have what's
called a lotus dna library prep kit it
also uses a transposon based
method
so they have a method on their website
that you can use the midnight panel with
their lotus library prep kit to
run these samples on illumina sequencing
so just to summarize um the midnight
method
builds on the arctic method
um and it works really well for rapid
inexpensive whole genome sequencing
it works well for labs with limited
funding if you use nanopore sequencing
and it really has had i think a global
impact in helping collect
information and genomic data on sars
cove 2 around the world
and none of this would be possible
without um
a lot of people's help and work
so
olin salander is a collaborator who
deserves equal credit i mean he has done
a ton of work on this marquetta
is a phd student in our lab who's also
helped a lot
labplus helped us get
early in the pandemic patient samples
that we could use to test this method
james connell is our biosafety officer
who also helped us work with um
inactivated cove samples in our lab
um esr team which is our
the team in wellington and auckland who
actually now do all of the coded
sequencing for the government especially
yup delict and uniren have been really
helpful for us in
discussing protocols and they've taken
our method on board which is really
awesome to see
and all of this work was funded by the
hrc the health research council of new
zealand we
obtained a covid rapid response from
fund from them and that helped pay for
all of this work
okay so at this stage i just want to say
thank you very much and i can take
questions and through the chat i think
and um i welcome any comments or
suggestions and feel free to get in
touch